TOMORROW NIGHT AT 7:00.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
LIKE MOST PEOPLE YOU
PROBABLY HAVEN'T BEEN
WATCHING A LOT OF CNN
LATELY.
BUT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THEY
STAGED A TELEVISED TOWN HALL
MEETING ON GUN CONTROL LAST
NIGHT.
IT SEEMED LIKE ONE OF THOSE
CULTURAL MOMENTS WORTH BEING
AWARE OF FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES WE WANT TO SHOW YOU
A SHORT CLIP OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
HERE IT IS.
[SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: WAIT, SORRY, I'M
SO SORRY.
TWO MINUTE HATE SCENE 1984.
WE GOT THE FOOTAGE CONFUSED
IT WAS EASY TO DO.
HERE IS THE CNN VERSION OF
THAT.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING ABOUT IS THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN.
>> YES.
>> YES, SIR.
>> SO LET ME BE HONEST WITH
YOU ABOUT THAT ONE.
IF I BELIEVED THAT THAT LAW
WOULD HAVE PREVENTED THIS
FROM HAPPENING, I WOULD
SUPPORT IT.
[CROWD BOOING]
>> I WANT TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
WHY IT WOULD NOT.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU WILL NOT ACCEPT A
SINGLE DONATION FROM THE NRA
IN THE FUTURE?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I WISH THE NRA LADY I COULD
HAVE TALKED TO BECAUSE I
WOULD ASK HER HOW SHE CAN
LOOK IN THE MIRROR
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS CHILDREN.
>> LET ME ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
LET ME ANSWER THE QUESTION.
CAN YOU SHOUT ME DOWN WHEN
I'M FINISHED BUT LET ME
ANSWER HIS QUESTION.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN BARRED
FROM GETTING A FIREARM.
AND AS I.
>> LEGALLY.
HE BOUGHT IT LEGALLY.
>> HE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE.
>> TO THEN WHY HASN'T DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
>> IF I COULD CHANGE TIME
AND CHANGE CIRCUMSTANCES, I
WOULD HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
IN MY POWER TO PREVENT THAT.
[SHOUTING]
>> YOU JUST TOLD THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
STANDING UP FOR THEM.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR
THEM UNTIL YOU SAY I
WEAPONS.
>> I WANT TO THANK DANA
LOESCH OF THE NRA AND
SHERIFF SCOTT FOR BEING HERE
TO LISTEN TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
[CROWD BOOING]
>> Tucker: EMOTIONS WERE
INFLAMED.
YELLING AND NASTY TZ DON'T
HELP ANYONE.
PRECISELY IN TIMES OF
TRAGEDY AND DISTRESS THAT WE
NEED CALMEST AND MOST
THOUGHTFUL VOICES.
CNN LAST NIGHT BROUGHT US
THE OPPOSITE.
THEY DID IT TO MAKE MONEY.
BUT THEY ALSO DID IT FOR
IDEOLOGICAL REASONS.
THAT WASN'T A TOWN HALL
MEETING AND IT CERTAINLY
WASN'T A NEWS EVENT.
IT WAS AN ACT OF RITUAL
PUBLIC HUMILIATION FOR
ANYBODY WHO DISAGREES WITH
CNN'S TRANSAPPARENTLY CLEAR
POSITION AGAINST GUN RIGHTS.
DANA LOESCH WAS THERE LAST
NIGHT.
SHE WAS THE ONE YOU JUST SAW
BEING CALLED A MURDERER ON
STAGE.
SHE SPOKE ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCE EARLIER TODAY.
>> MANY IN LEGACY MEDIA LOVE
MASS SHOOTINGS.
YOU GUYS LOVE IT NOW I'M NOT
SAYING THAT YOU LOVE THE
TRAGEDY.
BUT I AM SAYING THAT YOU
LOVE THE RATINGS.
CRYING WHITE MOTHERS ARE
RATINGS GOLD TO YOU AND MANY
IN THE LEGACY MEDIA IN THE
BACK.
AND NOTICE I SAID CRYING
WHITE MOTHERS BECAUSE THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF GRIEVING
BLACK MOTHERS IN CHICAGO
EVERY WEEKEND AND YOU DON'T
SEE TOWN HALLS FOR THEM, DO
YOU?
>> Tucker: SHE IS CERTAINLY
RIGHT ABOUT THE DEEP
CORRUPTION OF THE NEWS
MEDIA.
HOW CORRUPT?
WELL HBO HELPED LEAD TOLL
SAFETY.
WENT TO THE CNN EVENT LAST
NIGHT OR WPRI-12ED TO.
CNN PRODUCERS REWROTE THE
QUESTION HE WANTED TO ASK.